[Music]
if you're familiar with the premise of
far cry then you know exactly what far
cry 5 feels like you'll engage in
different styles of offensive conflict
attempt to tame the wild natural
environment to your advantage and slowly
build a guerrilla resistance in the
background but for its 5th main line
entry the series formula has undergone
some very positive refinements which
make its call hook of exploring and
engaging with volatile setting a more
free-flowing and pleasant experience one
that lets you enjoy the sights and
activities of it's beautiful and
interesting open world without too many
overt distractions the biggest change is
that the series is finally competent
enough to put you in charge of your own
progression after a brief orientation
the entirety of herp County is
immediately opened for exploration 3
intimidatingly large regions surround
your starting point and you're given
only a gentle suggestion of a good first
destination the moment when you're shown
all the equally accessible possibilities
and the furthest reaches of the map
feels liberating you may even be
crippled by the choice and that's a good
problem to have to accompany this
decision far cry 5 now handles it's
story progression in a more freeform
manner the goal in each of the three
regions is to earn enough resistance
points to hit three milestones and
subsequently have three encounters with
three lieutenants of the Eden's gate
cult with the ultimate goal of reaching
their leader Joseph seed of the Father
each of these individuals runs a
different facet of the god-fearing group
but their role in the story ultimately
isn't as interesting as you might think
despite 5x5 s potential for a
controversial and politically charged
narrative completing story and side
missions is the most efficient way to
and resistance points but you can also
viably achieve your goal by performing
smaller tasks that you might stumble
across during your journeys this
includes rescuing civilians in random
encounters finding and destroying cult
property and liberating cult outposts
mechanically it's a great player
friendly system that rewards you no
matter what activities you decide to do
or not do but the reason why it feels so
good an execution is because of how you
discover these opportunities in the
first place with the exception of each
region's hub area and the whereabouts of
specialists who are support characters
with unique abilities no points of
interest Omar
and the practice of finding and scaling
towel is to populate your map with icons
has been removed
discovering points of interest can be
achieved in a few ways
physically stumbling upon a significant
area will mark it on your map actively
looking at wildlife road signs inform
you of the fauna in that region finding
notes maps and magazines and homes and
other buildings can point you to a
number of different things including
prepa stashes which involve solving
obscure environmental puzzles that can
lead to money and gear simply running
into a civilian might give you the
chance to talk to them about the latest
word on the grapevine about an outpost
sidequest or even the location of a
story quest giver all of these elements
work wonderfully together to create a
style of larger progression that feels
mostly organic things can start off a
little broad but you'll naturally make
discoveries along the way that can lead
you off in different directions and
since you usually don't have anything
better going on you can explore the
distractions you might find with genuine
curiosity as opposed to because it was
one of a dozen icons who arbitrarily
picked as they stared at you from a
mini-map in fact there is no mini-map
and it's one of the best things to
happen to the series as was also the
case in Far Cry 2 there's a compass that
helps you track your direction and will
narrow down the general location of
enemies and marked objectives but
there's nothing telling you about the
specifics of an area the lack of
mini-map allows you to see the trees in
the forest so to speak you can focus on
details in the world without distraction
and you can actively appreciate the
stunning beauty of the natural
environment and pay full attention to
the intricate interior details in the
homes and businesses you visit the new
freeform flow sits comfortably while
with the most celebrated aspect of the
Far Cry series the capacity for you to
engage with the game's complex in your
own way seeing what kinds of chance
knives you stumble into and attaining
those water-cooler tales about what
happens next
[Music]
there's also thankfully less of an
emphasis on hunting selling animal skins
is the most lucrative way to earn money
for weapons and vehicles but the series
is finally past the point of needing to
hunt specific creatures for the purposes
of crafting upgrades another fantastic
change involves the affirmation
specialists and the more generic guns
for hire they allow you to command the
unique skills of one of many support
buddies adding another fun and dynamic
element to your toolkit specialists
provide a variety of options from the
humans that lay down covering fire with
different weapons and vehicles to the
animals who can assist you in marking
enemies and stealth takedowns they're
fantastic assets you can complement your
skillset or fill in a necessary gap you
might recruit torture to Archer just to
give you a sound and attack option all
tell the helicopter pilot Adelaide to
fly in and provide suppressing fire and
a distraction
Herk is also back for better or worse
the AI that drives support characters
sometimes makes poor decisions that puts
them in harm's away but in lieu of a
co-op partner specialists help bolster
the series's propensity for emergent
fist-pumping Hellyeah moments
and that's what 5x5 is all about fluid
and dynamic engagements that act as
different canvases and let you use the
game's variety of tools to finish the
picture at least that's the case most of
the time there are a number of major
story missions which are a lot more
linear and depending on your patience
they can be intolerable once you've hit
a milestone in the breading region the
Eaton's gate lieutenant in charge will
capture you whisking you away from the
world no matter what you're doing you'll
escape each time of course and then plow
through single style corridor affairs
until you escape or reach a boss fight
to kill the lieutenant these missions
showcase some pretty stunning set pieces
but mechanically they're bland at best
featuring elementary stealth challenges
on Rails tired sequences and monotonous
platforming among other scenarios
they're relatively brief but they're
semi regular occurrences that pull you
away from the world that makes Far Cry 5
great and it's easy to hold that against
them what makes these missions more
egregious are the prolonged close-up
encounters with the seed family members
upon capture joseph's seed and his
lieutenants are nothing if not
charismatic villains and their
performances are impressive but every
encounter you have with them is the same
your restrained in some manner and you
can do nothing but watch them get all up
in your face preaching about topics that
make sure you know just how evil they
are which becomes tiresome very quickly
Qwest skipper characters are mostly
extreme caricatures you'll either love
or hate but for the most part you're not
asked to put much investment in their
livelihood outside of the outrageous
quests they give you they'll send you on
adventures that show you the goofy side
of far cry from hunting down alien
turkeys for a mad scientist or watching
cows mate as Marvin Gaye's sexual
healing plays these missions feel more
in line with the freewheeling spirit of
far cry the see family missions
ultimately aren't an enormous detraction
but there are additional gripes weapons
and vehicles that have the capacity to
be purchased with real-world money take
prominent positions in every shop menu
and their connection to an online
storefront also seems to increase the
loading time of these menus by a few
beats which is annoying if all you want
to do is swap weapons and despite far
cry fives unquestionably relevant
religiously and politically volatile
setting the game doesn't do or say
anything interesting with it beyond a
few hammy jabs here and there it's
unchallenging satire and for the
attention paid to the seed family you'd
expect there to be something more but
there are so many more simple
experiential joys to be found in Far Cry
5 the exhilarating skill of jumping off
a mountain and flying through the skies
in a wingsuit
the idle banter between your specialists
fishing in one of the many rivers or
lakes for hours on end petting your
animal companions flying a plane for the
first time in the series
the tight and precise gunplay the
relaxing feeling of cruising down a
picturesque highway in a 70s muscle car
listening to the great selection of
classic rock and country tunes on the
radio
if you'd rather experience this with
someone who's a little more autonomous
or you prefer your waltz to be a little
more bonkers far cry 5 also includes a
couple of major features to player
online co-op for the campaign and far
cry arcade co-op has a few restrictions
being unable to save your admission
progress unless you're the host is a
disappointing one but if you're happy to
simply be that extra gun-for-hire
there's a lot of joy to be found in
sharing far crys exciting impromptu
moments because you have someone to rave
about it with immediately afterwards ok
it has the game's custom map editor
allowing you to build in player in
single player co-op or competitive
multiplayer maps all play maps uploaded
by the rest of the community while the
process of jumping into custom maps
requires a lot of patience to cater for
the lengthy download and loading times
arcade provides the potential for a
diverse array of levels and game modes
that are far removed from the tone and
rules of the main game although the hope
county denizen that pimps [ __ ] arcade
deserves a mention as one of the most
irritating characters in the game the
editor itself is robust and the asset
library is generous offering resources
from other Ubisoft games on top of the
one from the Far Cry series it'll take
you some time to get familiar with it
but with diligence it's obvious that the
results can be amazing levels created by
Ubisoft are a prime example of how
interesting they can be but there are a
lot of bland examples out there too it's
easy to weed out that duds when you're
picking and choosing single-player
levels but when it comes to multiplayer
you leave some of that up to chance
three players in a multiplayer Lobby are
selected to pick an upcoming map with
the rest of the lobby burning between
them and a server selected option there
are already some wonderful pvp maps but
there are also a fair share of ugly
empty maps with poorly thought-out
modifiers it's great to see people
experimenting but you're not required to
publish any of your work so it's a
little annoying post match you're asked
to like or dislike a map that will help
with ratings so we're hopeful that after
a while the cream will flow to the top
despite some brief irritations and
missed opportunities with its narrative
spending time in the world of hope
county remains absolutely delightful far
cry 5 boasts a wonderfully harmonious
flow to its adventure with its smart
changes to exploration discovery and
progression distinctly bolstering the
enjoyment of creatively engaging and
experimenting with it's spectacular open
wall
[Music]
you
[Music]